Charter school authorizing is important.
It helps ensure that charter schools are responsible stewards of their students and of public funds. Good authorizers don't give license to mediocrity,
but they must also protect the autonomy that enables vibrant schools to flourish. As NASCA
president Greg Richmond has observed: "In both the red and blue states last year, we saw legislation proposed that would have dictated
what a charter school should be, rather than what outcomes taxpayers should hold it accountable for
These bills required certain curriculum certain discipline models and certain teacher principal and staff
certification requirements. Look the easiest thing in the world is to insist on just one more rule that charter schools should follow.
But the accretion of rules over time creates a sclerosis that leaves school stuck and
educators frustrated. If charter schools are to deliver on their promise
Authorizers must help ensure that educators can create terrific classrooms and not simply to recreate
familiar, hidebound bureaucracies.
What do you think about charter schools?
Let us know in our poll. Also,
let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to LIKE and subscribe
for more research and videos from AEI